you
yeah it's hard to tell of course but
that I've been interested in science
certainly from a child I'd meant I was
mostly interested in numbers I was
calculating things at a very young age I
just fell in love with numbers and then
it spread from there to the rest of
nature and I became I remember the total
eclipse of the Sun which happened when I
was three and I was furious with my
father because he wouldn't take us to
see it she would have meant about about
it the whole day's driving and anyway so
he said no you can see the partial
eclipse and that's it and I thought that
was terribly unfair
so when I never learned much science in
school that was I think an advantage in
the old days I grew up in England and we
spent most of the time on Latin and
Greek and very little on science and I
think that was good because it meant we
didn't get turned off it was science was
something we did for fun and not because
we had to
yes well I was 15 when the war started
so for a long time I just stayed in
school but then so it well I was lucky I
had only two years of the war and so I
went to work for the Royal Air Force
when I was 19 which was already just two
years before it ended so I went to the
bomber command headquarters and that was
July 43 and so I had just two years of
it the last two years and I was working
as a statistician mostly just collecting
all the information about the air force
operations particularly the bombing of
Germany so I had a sort of front for a
front row seat view of that of course it
was a total shambles that the whole
campaign was a great tragedy for both
sides and there was nothing I could do
about it